the markets in China have been extremely
volatile and there's concern about a
broader downturn you know what what are
you most optimistic about but and what
gives you the most cause for
concern well um well I am I am somewhat
concerned about the you know the
frothiness of of the markets I'd say not
just in China but but everywhere that
you know we've had uh we've had uh this
u i i i don't think the if there's a
bubble today um I don't think the bubble
is centered on technology um uh neither
in China nor nor in the US I think um I
think bubbles are psychosocial phenomena
um you know we got the public you have
to get the public involved in a in a
crazy way um you know in the 9s we had
in 1999 we had 300 Tech IPOs in the US
in 2015 there may be 15 or 20 Tech IPOs
depending on how you count them um so
the public has not been involved in um
in the tech boom this time around um a
little bit more in China not at all in
the US so I think there's no no bubble
centered on technology if there's a
bubble it's probably at this point
centered on the 0% interest rates the
quantitative easing the money
Printing and um and that's a very
strange one because that's one that
permeates everything so that uh yeah
startup tech stocks may be overvalued
but so are public equities so are houses
so are government bonds because uh that
sort of touches everything um and in
some ways I I I've actually argued that
in some ways Silicon Valley is quite far
from it because if the bubble in cash uh
the things that are very far from cash
say IL liquid startup Investments may be
actually a place to hide